[Music]
the hottest show on television is about
to get cold Bennigan's back on our TVs
again how did you make the decision to
say yes to winter games this franchise
has been really good to me even through
some of the difficulties and the things
that haven't worked out it's still been
good for me it's helped me find love and
tell me fall in love it's helped me know
what true love feels like does this mean
that Ben Higgins is ready to find love
again I am ready to find love again it
takes a while well it's not an easy
process it's still one that I'm sure has
its shakiness too and I probably haven't
thought through a processed or dealt
with all the emotions that tie to
falling back in love but I am ready I'm
excited for it
I feel more ready today than I did two
years ago have you dated at all I have
David yeah it's been it's been difficult
it took me a long time it took me a long
time to kind of even start to flirt or
text or call or follow up with somebody
that I met that I you know had interest
in it's weird it's really weird alright
it's hard to come up with ideas for
dates oh I forgot how difficult is to
put the effort in the dating getting
from the mindset of being a committed
relationship one that you believe is
gonna be a forever thing and then that
relationship ends and moving into being
single again that transition was weird
for me for months I still felt like I
was doing something wrong
how did you know that it was not that
for everything
when it ended yeah I'd say probably when
it ended I knew it was no longer for
everything
was that surprising to you um yeah we
have great examples just in life of
people that I've really try hard and two
great people that really want to love
each other and they just can so that is
surprising The Bachelor is going
international from different countries
could you see yourself falling in love
with a foreigner yeah definitely I could
find myself falling in love with a
foreigner that's that's not even a
question the bigger question is you know
logistical 'hey how did that work this
could be a terrible mistake or it can be
a huge success you'll have to watch what
the [ __ ] along with me
you